es la escena del horror más extremo
cuerpos calcinados entre las ruinas de
la prisión de olenifka en la región
separatista purorusa de doñazca luego de
un bombardeo que deja decenas de
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos muertos
y casi un centenar de heridos 53 muertos
71 heridos los números pueden cambiar
inicialmente eran 40 algunos murieron
camino al hospital algunos murieron en
el hospital pero actualmente estos son
los números 53 muertos y 71 heridos
Rusia y sus aliados en la región
acusaron inmediatamente a kiev de ser el
autor del ataque con misiles de alta
precisión
el centro de detención en la zona del
asentamiento de olenifka donde se
encontraban prisioneros de guerra
ucranianos incluidos los combatientes de
la formación a soft fue alcanzado por un
misil lanzado por el sistema de cohetes
y Mars de fabricación estadounidense
murieron 40 prisioneros de guerra
ucranianos y 75 resultaron heridos
Ucrania por su parte lo niega
rotundamente y culpa al kremlin de
llevar a cabo deliberado de terrorismo
para encubrir supuestas torturas y
ejecuciones de ucranianos encarcelados
allí Rusia ha cometido otro crimen de
guerra petrificante al bombardear un
centro penitenciario en la ocupada o
lenisca donde tenía prisioneros de
guerra ucranianos hago un llamado a
todos los socios para que condenen
enérgicamente esta brutal violación del
derecho internacional humanitario y
reconozca a Rusia como un estado
terrorista un cruce de acusaciones que
no ha podido ser verificado de forma
independiente por ningún organismo pero
que constituye una violación del derecho
internacional humanitario y un crimen de